so what is dance dance itself is if the
art of Illusion right what am I where am
I am I here am i there people don't
understand them they just want to talk
not do this you know I mean I'm not a
dancer I'm more of a magician because
you you should be getting this imagery
trick going on you see what I'm saying
am i a robot Oh a powering down no press
me up I'm alive again that everybody
wants to be a dancer
everybody wants to be a dancer you up on
YouTube you do a little pop it moves
suddenly you a dancer fill up the pacman
shebib my name is that pac-man
nobody even plays that game anymore it's
what my name is David the Xbox 360 hit
an interesting fact for you before dance
was known as dance it used to be called
David what's up man y'all want to go
David later behind man I just David in
my ass off yesterday it's because all
you kids don't know about the basics of
dancing you know who started it all
humpty-dumpty way the stomach tickles
sir pops in love Tickle Me elbow it's
not a Slumdog Millionaire story where I
started off really bad or poor and then
end it off is great you see I started
off that great and that ended at the
best